Black holes are one of the strangest things in existence.
They don't seem to make any sense at all.
Where do they come from?
And what happens if you fall into one?
Stars are incredibly massive collections of mostly hydrogen atoms that collapsed
from enormous gas cloud to under their own gravity.
In that core,
nuclear fusion crushes hydrogen atoms into helium really seen a tremendous
amount of energy.
This energy in the form of radiation pushes against gravity maintaining a
delicate balance between the two forces.
As long as there is fusion in the corps and he star remains stable enough,
but for stars with way more mass than our own sun,
the heat and pressure at the core allow them to fuse heavier elements until they
retired.
Unlike all the elements that went before the fusion process that creates iron
doesn't generate any energy.
Iron builds up at the center of the Star until it reaches a critical amount and
the balance between radiation and gravity is suddenly broken.
The core collapses within a fraction of a second.
The star implodes moving at about a quarter of the speed of light feeding even
more mass into the core.
It's at this very moment that all the heavier elements in the universe are
created.
As the star dies in a supernova explosion,
this produces either a neutron star or if the star is massive enough,
the entire mass of the core collapses into a black hole.
If you looked at a black hole,
what you'd already be seeing is the event horizon.
Anything that crosses the event horizon needs to be traveling faster than the
speed of light to escape.
In other words,
it's impossible,
so we just see a black sphere reflecting nothing,
but if the event horizon is the black part,
what is the whole part of the black hole?
The singularity,
we're not sure what it is exactly.
A singularity,
maybe infinitely dense,
meaning all its mass is concentrated into a single point in space with no
surface,
all volume or something completely different.
Right now we just don't know.
It's like a dividing by zero error.
By the way,
black holes do not suck things up like a vacuum cleaner.
If we were to swap the sun for an equity massive black hole,
nothing much would change for us except that we would freeze to death.
Of course,
what would happen to you if you fell into a black hole?
The experience of time is different around black holes from the outside.
You seem to slow down as you approached the event horizon,
so time passes slower for you.
At some point you would appear to freeze in time,
slowly turn red and disappear.
While from your perspective you can watch the rest of the university and fast
forward kind of like seeing into the future.
Right now we don't know what happens next but we think it could be one of two
things.
One,
you die a quick death of black coal,
curved space so much that once you cross the event horizon,
there is only one possible direction.
You can take this literally inside the event horizon.
You can only go in one direction.
It's like being in a really tight Annie that closes behind you.
After each step,
the massive black hole is so concentrated.
At some point,
even tiny distances of a few centimeters would mean that gravity acts with
millions of times more force on different parts of your body.
Your cells get torn apart as your body stretches more and more until you're a
hot stream of plasma one atom wide to you die a very quick death.
Very soon after you cross the event horizon,
you would hit a fly wheel and be terminated in an instant.
Neither of these options are good.
Tickety pleasant.
How soon you would die depends on the mass of the black hole.
A smaller black hole would kill you before you even entered.
It's a vent horizon.
While you probably could travel inside a supermassive black hole for quite a
while.
As a rule of thumb,
the further away from the singularity you are,
the longer you live,
black holes come in different sizes.
There are stellar mass black holes with a few times the mass of the sun and the
diamonds of an asteroid,
and then there are these super massive black holes which are found at the heart
of every galaxy and have been feeding for billions of years.
Currently the largest supermassive black hole known as s five zero zero one four
plus eight one 40 billion times the mass of our sun.
It is 236.7 billion kilometers in diameter,
which is 47 times the distance from the sun to Pluto.
As powerful as black holes are,
they will eventually evaporate through a process called hawking radiation.
To understand how this works,
we have to look at empty space.
Empty space is not really empty,
but filled with virtual particles popping into existence and annihilating each
other.
Again,
when this happens right on the edge of a black hole,
one of the virtual particles will be drawn into the black hole and the other
will escape and become a real particle.
So the black hole is losing energy.
This happens incredibly slowly at first and gets faster as the black hole become
smaller.
When it arrives at the massive a large asteroid,
it's radiating it to room temperature.
When it has the massive amount in,
it radiates with about the heat of our son and in the last second of its life,
the black hole radiates away with the energy of the billions of nuclear bombs in
a huge explosion.
But this process is incredibly slow.
The biggest black holes we know might take up to eight Google old years to
evaporate.
This is so long that when the last black hole radiates away,
nobody will be around to witness it.
The universe will have become uninhabitable long before then.
This is not the end of our story.
There are loads more interesting ideas about black holes.
We'll explore them in part to
a big thanks to phrase it came for help with this video.
By the way,
we've made some coats cause we'll pay was in four k for different screen sizes.
You can get them on our page,
you on page,
which also helps us to make more videos like this.
December the first month ever with three videos.